i've always said this about facebook
about twitter about youtube they operate
in the united states so you need to
adhere the united states laws right we
have free speech laws you need to adhere
to those laws because those are the laws
that allowed your company to flourish
now that doesn't apply when you have a
company like bite dance that has
irrefutable ties to the communist
chinese party okay so in august the
chinese government they took a stake of
um well a few things they took a board
seat in beijing uh the bite dance
technology company i am going to close
my tick tock
the nine dash line isn't real
mao's great leap forward led to the
death of 45 million chinese citizens
taiwan is in fact a real country and uh
not a part of communist china [ __ ] the
ccp
and i encourage every single one of you
to delete your own tick tocks if you
have it stop buying into the ccp
subversion and let us know if you
deleted it share a picture and using the
hashtag trashticktalk